radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene I
guess wants to ban the pornography site
PornHub
because of something related to Hunter
Biden this one's really difficult to
understand Daily Beast has a piece on it
Marjorie Taylor green wants to ban
PornHub because of Hunter Biden
Marjorie Taylor green is disgusted that
websites like PornHub exist and even
more horrified that Hunter Biden may
have used them
Raw Story reports that green shared her
Newfound knowledge of the adult film
landscape in a keynote addressed to the
Putnam County Ohio Lincoln Reagan dinner
let's listen to what she had to say
about PornHub and Hunter Biden this is
really weird United States doesn't want
biological brainchild
here's what I found out this way
there is a website you may or may not
have heard about it called PornHub
it is a disgusting porn website as a
matter of fact it should be illegal I
can't even I don't even know why it
exists
right they're against business
regulation
but ban the website
the hunter Biden used to have
burnt Hub pornography sex website
and these aren't accounts where he could
go watch pornography these are accounts
where he posted his sex videos oh like
the ones that are on the hunter Biden
laptop
this week I found out you want to know
what
has
whoa now I would also wonder does he
have Gmail and should Gmail be banned
does he have a New York Times
subscription should we ban the New York
Times this is so stupid but the crowd is
just enraptured by Marjorie Taylor green
telling the story where his videos are
posted
it is still live and active
this is the son of the president of the
United States
did someone just say fraudulent I gotta
I want to go back and hear that again
this is the son of the president of the
United States fraudulent yeah what's
fraudulent
the most disgusting
vile embarrassment piece of trash and
that is what is a reflection on our
country
jeez then in that case how does Marjorie
Taylor green reflect on our country
that's scary stuff and they attacked
president Trump and his family
I don't care how people vote Republican
Democrat independent
non-political whatever
that fact right there should be so
offensive to every single American that
we do something about it
this political cycle has gotten so
stupid so so stupid so there's a couple
different things number one the idea
that a low regulation stay out of
business's way Etc Republican would want
a website banned made illegal
and of course when she says that it's
like should it be illegal to run the
website should it be illegal to visit
the website they're never really clear
you know the website should be illegal
because Hunter Biden has an account on
the website is some of the most specious
reasoning that I can imagine and again
to what other platforms I mean I don't
does Hunter Biden have a Twitter account
should Twitter be illegal because Hunter
Biden in theory could post videos to
twitter and he has an account there and
Twitter hasn't even closed it I don't
know the answer to that and it's again
another reminder they have their stated
principles
which matter not at all to them when
it's inconvenient and then all of a
sudden it's banned this ban that the
other thing the other thing I want to
mention is I continue to get emails
about why am I not talking about Hunter
Biden
what do you want me to say about Hunter
Biden the images that were not allowed
on Twitter around the time of the 2020
election
were
um images
sexually explicit images that were being
published without Hunter Biden's consent
that's illegal in Most states and
against Twitter's terms of service now
if you want to make the argument that
were those images not part of the
articles that were being posted the
article should have been allowed I'm
with you and in fact as I mentioned
earlier I just finished recording uh an
episode with Lex Friedman
for his podcast and the topic of Hunter
Biden came up and we talked about it a
little bit you know at this point it's
like do you still not have the evidence
to charge Hunter Biden for all of the
crimes he supposedly committed if he's
committed crimes go ahead and charge him
I don't know anyone on the left who
would say no he must be protected or
whatever else the case may be the fact
that it has been this long and Rudy
Giuliani had the hard drive Tucker had
the hard drive and look got lost in the
mail and the blind computer guy had the
hard drive all these different things
and there's still no evidence of any
criminality of any substance maybe he
didn't really commit crimes I don't know
but I have no issue whatsoever with
Hunter Biden being investigated charged
prosecute whatever to the fullest extent
of the law but there's nothing else for
me to say about it at this point in time
given the fact that there doesn't seem
to be evidence that he committed any
crimes and certainly he has no
involvement in the Biden Administration
so that's where I am on the hunter Biden
stuff
we'll do a deeper conversation on it on
the Lex Friedman podcast because uh
because Lex brought it up all right so
that'll be released in the next few days
one of our sponsors is electric e-bikes
I've been watching e-bike reviews on
YouTube for a while because I've been
thinking of getting one and I
continually come across electric as the
brand to go with if your budget is
between 800 and 1300 and I have to agree
from experience I've had my electric
e-bike for a little while now I've
almost ditched my car and regularly bike
at this point for errands and things
around my neighborhood it's awesome
cardio because I'm still pedaling I get
there faster I can see more I'm reducing
my carbon footprint the e-bike came to
my doorstep fully assembled it has a
bright LCD screen seven speed gearing
five levels of pedal assist a powerful
battery that you can take inside to
charge it's also fully foldable I can
put it in the back of my car electric
has models for every lifestyle and you
can Finance for as little as 73 bucks a
month go to electricebikes.com to learn
more explore all of the incredible
e-bike models they offer the link is
down below